So now that we are finished designing our project, here
is your assignment. We want you to show the program
we've written together to a friend or a colleague. Now,
you can continue to use the Profanity Editor website which
is wdyl.com, or you can use some sort of a
different internet service like Pirate Speech. By the way, the
link to this is available in the instructor notes. While
you are doing that we want you to use your smart
phone to record a video of the conversation with your
friend or colleague. And then we want you to share your
YouTube video with us on the discussion forum. Make sure
you check this box after submitting your responses on the forum.